ZDF heute live hallo zusammen schön dass
ihr bei uns seit die ganze Nacht bis in
die frühen Morgenstunden wurde um eine
Lösung im Kanzleramt gerungen im
haushaltstreit und jetzt ist sie da und
deshalb geben wir direkt rüber zur
Pressekonferenz nach
Berlin Verfassungsgericht bekanntlich
ein sehr weitreichendes Urteil
gesprochen dieses Urteil hat Auswirkung
auf den aktuellen und auf den kommenden
Bundeshaushalt und grundsätzlich auf die
Art und Weise wie wir Haushalte im Bund
und in den Ländern
Aufstellen im Lichte des Urteils haben
wir in den vergangenen Wochen in der
Bundesregierung den Haushalt neu
priorisiert die Gespräche das darf ich
Ihnen hier gern verraten liefen
vertrauensvoll sie liefen vertraulich
das haben sie mitbekommen und sie liefen
sehr konstruktiv dafür bin ich allen
Beteiligten aus arücklich sehr
dankbar heute nun stehen wir ich als
Bundeskanzler der Vizekanzler und der
Bundesminister der Finanzen vor Ihnen um
Sie über das Ergebnis dieser Beratung zu
informieren meine wichtigste Botschaft
zu beginnen die Regierung hält an ihren
Zielen fest wir treiben den
klimaneutralen Umbau unseres Landes
kraftvoll voran wir stärken den sozialen
Zusammenhalt und wir stehen eng an der
Seite der Ukraine in ihrem Verteidigung
Kampf gegen
Russland diese drei Ziele leiten uns
unverändert klar ist aber wir müssen mit
deutlich weniger Geld auskommen um diese
Ziele zu erreichen priorisieren heißt
deshalb miteinander zu klären was wir
uns leisten
können und was
nicht es geht auch um Kürzung und
Einsparung die machen wir nicht gerne
klar sie sind aber nötig damit wir mit
dem Geld was uns zur Verfügung steht
hinkommen solche schwierigen
Haushaltsgespräche dauern in der Regel
mehrere Monate wir haben sie nun
innerhalb einiger Wochen
geführt zu den konkreten Fakten im
Kernhaushalt für das Jahr 2024 werden
wir rund 17 Milliarden Euro
erwirtschaften das machen wir
insbesondere indem wir klimaschädliche
Subventionen abschaffen die Ausgaben
einzelner Ressource etwas absenken und
Bundeszuschüsse
verringern das zentrale Instrument des
Bundes für den klimaneutralen Umbau
unseres Landes bleibt der Klima und
transformationsfond aufgrund der
Vorgaben der Verfassungsrichter
verringern wir allerdings die Ausgaben
des Fonds im nächsten Jahr um 12
Milliarden Euro im
Finanzplanungszeitraum bis
2027 kürzen wir um etwa 45 Milliarden
Euro der KTF hat damit aber immer noch
ein sehr hohes Gesamtvolumen von 160
Milliarden Euro und noch eine Frage die
sicherlich viele beschäftigt was
bedeutet all das für die Schuldenregel
des
Grundgesetzes mit dem Haushalt 2024
halten wir die Schuldenregel nach
Artikel 115 des Grundgesetzes
ein das Grundgesetz sieht ausdrücklich
vor dass die kreditobergrenzen zur
Bewältigung von Naturkatastrophen und
außergewöhnlichen Notsituationen
angehoben werden können das haben wir
mit Blick auf die Hochwasserkatastrophe
im ail 2021 gemacht und ein
sondervermögenhöhe von 16 Milliarden
Euro
aufgelegt aufgrund des Urteils des
Verfassungsgericht müssen solche
Vermögen jedes Jahr neu beschlossen
werden das haben wir getan der Bundestag
wird am Freitag einen entsprechenden
Beschluss für das laufende Jahr treffen
für das nächste Jahr geht es um einen
Betrag von 2,7 Milliarden Euro für den
wir den überschreitensbeschluss nach
Artikel 115 Absatz 2 6 des Grundgesetzes
vorsehen möchten dazu laufen allerdings
notwendigerweise nochmals vertiefte
Prüfung wir werden auch auf die größte
Oppositionspartei zugehen und um deren
Unterstützung für diesen Schritt
werben denn die betroffenen Bürger und
Bürger in nordrin-westfalen und
rheinlandfalz sollen sich auch auf die
gegebenen Zusagen verlassen können mein
letzter
Punkt die Unterstützung der Ukraine
stellmen wir aus dem regelhaushalt so
wie wir es geplant haben und vor allem
so lange wie nötig dazu zählen 8
Milliarden Euro für Waffenlieferung
Finanzhilfen für den ukrainischen
Haushalt direkt oder über die
Europäische Union und voraussichtlich
über 6 Milliarden Euro zuur
Unterstützung ukrainischer Flüchtlinge
hier in
Deutschland sollte sich die Situation
durch russlandskrieg gegen die Ukraine
verschärfen etwa weil die Lage an der
Front sich verschlechtert weil andere
Unterstützer ihre ukrainehilfe
zurückfahren oder weil die Bedrohung für
Deutschland Europa weiter zunimmt werden
wir darauf reagieren
müssen um vorbereitet zu sein haben wir
bereits miteinander vereinbart in einer
solchen Lage von der heute niemand weiß
ob sie nun eintritt oder nicht dem
Bundestag ein überschreitensbeschluss
vorzuschlagen sowie Artikel 115 des
Grundgesetzes das in Notsituation
zulässt meine Damen und Herren bleibt
mir noch mich bei allen Beteiligten noch
einmal zu bedanken für die intensiven
konstruktiven und lösungsorientierten
Beratung die Vereinbarung werden wir nun
so schnell es geht im Kabinett
beschließen und dem Haushaltsgesetzgeber
übermitteln schönen
Dank ja vielen Dank sehrte Damen und
Herren erlauben Sie mir auch von meiner
Seite noch ein paar kommentierende
Bemerkungen wir haben uns nach
intensiven Gesprächen sie haben es ja
teilweise mit verfolgen können Gott sei
Dank nicht aus den Gesprächen selbst
aber die beratungstaktung ja doch
bekanntermaßen mitverfolgen können auf
ein großes Paket geeinigt das ist gut
und notwendig gewesen notwendig
natürlich auch obwohl wir große
Umschichtung vorgenommen haben weil
diese Beratung in einer Zeit großer
geopolitischer und
wirtschaftspolitischer Unsicherheit
stattgefunden hat und wir mit diesem
Beschluss heute die Verlässlichkeit das
Vertrauen das Wissen dass Deutschland
liefert wieder herstellen das ist
wichtig für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
das ist wichtig für die Unternehmen die
investieren wollen es ist wichtig für
die internationalen Partner die
Beschlüsse die wir gefasst haben und
jetzt den Fraktionen und den Parteien
zur Beratung noch einmal vorlegen werden
halten dass die Balance die wir uns
vorgenommen haben sie investieren weiter
in soziale Sicherheit in Zeiten der
Unsicherheit und sie sorgen für Impulse
für die wirtschaftliche Stabilität und
Erneuerung vor allem aber geben sie auch
der Ukraine in einer schwierigen Zeit
das schutzversprechen dass wir zu
unserem Wort stehen sicherlich ein
Signal dass auch Putin vernehmen wird
und auch soll die Lösung die wir
gefunden haben sie ist ja ausgelöst die
Frage durch die durch das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil das aus der
Rücklage des KTF 60 Milliarden
rausnimmt das bedeutet dass wir diese
Lücke schließen mussten das gelingt
durch verschiedene
Operationen zum Teil
gehen Beiträge die wir in den KTF getan
haben wieder raus das betrifft die
Bundesbahn und sie wird anders
finanziert aber sie wird finanziert das
ist keine
einsparmaßnahme wir werden die Einnahmen
des ktfs steigern indem wir auf den CO2
Fahrt der groko zurückkehren wir werden
umschichten im KTF und wir werden
einsparen einsparen bei Bereichen und da
bin ich den Kollegen sehr dankbar aus
dem Bau und dem Verkehrsministerium aber
natürlich auch in dem Bereich den ich
verantworte ich will zwei Beispiele
nennen wir werden die Umweltprämie also
die Förderung für immobile auslaufen
lassen früher beenden sie läuft ja eh
aus aber werden das früher tun und wir
werden bei einigen Programmen Teilen
kürzen beispielsweise bei der
Solarindustrie das tut mir weh aber das
ist der Preis dafür dass die zentralen
Bestandteile die Säulen des ktfs
erhalten bleiben der Aufbau der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft die
dekarbonisierung der Industrie aber eben
auch die bürgerprogramme die
Beibehaltung der EEG Umlage sei genannt
oder auch die Förderung im begeg also
die Förderung der wärmewende alle diese
zentralen sollen bleiben erhalten und
werden die Investition auslösen die wir
versprochen haben die wir uns damit
erhoffen und ein Impuls für die
wirtschaftliche Erneuerung Deutschlands
geben die verschiedenen Beiträge die die
Ressource Leisten sind erheblich aber
auch der Bundeshaushalt wird einen
Beitrag leisten weil wir einwart haben
dass es jetzt wieder die
zuschussmöglichkeit oder Zuschüsse für
den Klima und transformationsfond gibt
sodass das Schließen der Lücke durch
eine gemeinsame Kraftanstrengung
insgesamt gelungen ist wir damit jetzt
wieder eine Grundlage schaffen für das
Land in das Land zu
investieren ja meine Damen und Herren
das Bundeskabinett hat heute sich
beschäftigt mit dem
wichtigen Thema und dem ernstzunehmenden
Thema der Strategie g Einsamkeit ich
kann allerdings feststellen dass wir
drei in den letzten Wochen nicht
betroffen gewesen sind wir haben
intensiv gearbeitet und wir können hier
heute vor sie treten mit dem klaren
Signal diese Koalition ist handlungs und
einigungsfähig auch bei sehr schwierigen
Aufgaben das ist die erste von sieben
kurzen Bemerkungen die zweite wir setzen
den Kurs der fiskalischen Konsolidierung
fort im Jahr 2021 hat hat die deutsche
Schuldenquote 69% betragen im nächsten
Jahr ist prognostiziert 64%
2000 21 hatten wir ein jahresdefizit von
3,6% im nächsten Jahr gehen wir von
1,5% aus das heißt auch unter
Einbeziehung aller Sondervermögen und
nebenhaushalten stimmt der Kurs wir
haben eine Trendwende erreicht her
Bundeskanzler hat gesagt dass dies
deshalb möglich ist weil die
Orientierung an der Schuldenbremse für
uns äh weiter äh von großer Bedeutung äh
ist drittens die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung ist nicht zufriedenstellend
deshalb unternehmen wir Anstrengungen äh
um äh unser Land auf den
wirtschaftlichen erfolgsfahrt zu führen
dazu gehören rekordinvestitionen aus dem
Bundeshaushalt auch der KTF hat ein
enormes weiteres
Finanzierungsvolumen für die
transformativen Aufgaben wir gehen
teilweise auch kreative Wege
beispielsweise wollen wir
Privatisierungserlöse von nicht
benötigten bundesbeteiligungen teilweise
nutzen um die Bahn zu stärken zur
Stärkung der wirtschaftlichen Dynamik
gehören die 15 Milliarden Euro
Steuerentlastung bei der Lohn- und
Einkommenssteuer die im nächsten Jahr
wirksam werden 3 Milliarden Euro
stromsteuersenkung werden kommen daran
halten wir fest das haben wir möglich
gemacht und das
wachstumschancengesetz ist vollweit im
Haushaltsplan vorgesehen ich fordere
deshalb die CDU CSU auf
sich wieder zu beteiligen an den
Gesprächen in der Vorbereitung eines
Vermittlungsverfahrens damit auch dieser
Baustein zur Stärkung unserer
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung beschlossen
werden kann das wäre jedenfalls ein
starkes Signal für die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung diese Bundesregierung hat
jedenfalls das dafür notwendige getan
der vierte Punkt der Bundeskanzler und
auch der vizekanz zler haben völlig
zurecht unterstrichen welche besondere
Bedeutung die Unterstützung der Ukraine
für uns hat dort werden auch unsere
Werte verteidigt dort werd wird
entschieden über die europäische
Friedens und freiheitsordnung deshalb
sehen wir 8 Milliarden Euro an direkter
bilateraler Hilfe für die Ukraine vor
wir sind damit im weltweiten Vergleich
mit an der Spitze glaube man kann sagen
dass gut die hälftte der Hilfen aus
Europa für die Ukraine aus Deutschland
kommt und wir stellen uns auch weiter
dieser
Verantwortung sollte sich die Lage
verändern die internationale
Gemeinschaft gemeinsam Entscheidungen
treffen dann sind wir
vollhandlungsfähig und auch für die
Fälle wo die Möglichkeiten die der
Bundeshaushalt bereitstellt
überschritten werden könnten der Herr
Bundeskanzler hat das gerade
unterstrichen wir haben dann noch den
Punkt des aufbauhilfefonds äh der
Bundeskanzler hat auch das angesprochen
es ist unser Ziel den betroffenen
Menschen Unterstützung und
Rechtssicherheit zu geben der damalige
aufbauilfeefond der Vorgängerregierung
ist ja mit einem notlagenbeschluss eines
Sondervermögens beschlossen worden nach
der jetzigen Auslegung der
Schuldenbremse durch die durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht wäre das so
nicht mehr möglich dieses Vorhaben
weiter fortzusetzen auf der anderen
Seite ist das Finanzierungsvolumen von
2,7 Milliarden jetzt nicht ang die
Statik des Bundeshaushaltes zu gefährden
was wiederum bei der Auslegung der
Schuldenbremse seinerzeit
diskussionswürdig ist seinerseits
diskussionsfürdig ist und deshalb wie
der Bundeskanzler sagt prüfen wir jetzt
wie wir diese Rechtssicherheit
gewährleisten wollen die Anhörung zum
Haushalt abwarten und das Gespräch auch
mit der CDU CSU Fraktion suchen um einen
Weg zu finden hier Rechtssicherheit zu
geben fünftens das hat der Bundeskanzler
ebenfalls gesagt also sofern ist fast
alles schon gesagt wir bauen
klimaschädliche Subventionen ab in dem
Umfang von 3 Milliarden Euro dazu gehört
jetzt unter anderem
die im Koalitionsvertrag vorgesehene
plastikabgabe dabei handelt es sich um
ein EU Eigenmittel 1,4 Milliarden die
wir jetzt aus allgemeinen Steuermitteln
nach Brüssel überweisen das wollen wir
jetzt neu finanzieren und wollen wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen die wie
sagt man in verkehrbringer von Plastik
ähm für äh die Finanzierung dieses
eigenmittels nutzen die 3 Milliarden
klimaschädliche Subventionen finanzieren
also die Senkung der Stromsteuer man
könnte anders sagen alte nicht mehr
benötigte Subventionen helfen uns jetzt
in Zukunftsbereichen Schwerpunkte zu
setzen sechster und Vorletzter Punkt ähm
viele Ressource leisten eigene Beiträge
ähm beispielsweise das ähm
Verkehrsministerium auch äh das das
Umweltministerium ähm auch das
Arbeitsministerium wichtig ist aber es
wird keine Reduzierung von sozialen
Standards geben ist das gemeinsame
versprechen ja auch dieser Koalition
gewesen dennoch erreichen wir durch mehr
Treffsicherheit bei Sozialleistungen
eine Einsparung so haben wir uns das
vorgenommen von 1,5 Milliarden Euro auch
im Bereich des Arbeitsmarkts über die
bessere Vermittlung von den geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine beispielsweise und der
siebte und letzte Punkt der KTF hat im
nächsten Jahr weniger Ausgaben
12,7 Milliarden weniger in der ganzen
finanzplanperiode werden wir aber unsere
Ziele
erreichen dazu ist es notwendig dass wir
zum 1.1 des nächsten Jahres auf den
preisfahrt der großen Koalition
zurückkehren wir hatten uns ja
ursprünglich vorgenommen nur um 5 € den
CO2 Preis zu erhöhen wären damit
unterhalb des preisfades der großen
Koalition geblieben weil uns aber die
diese transformativen Vorhaben so
wichtig sind haben wir gesagt nein wir
machen jetzt den preisfahrt der groko
damit wir unsere und auch fürs Land
wichtige Vorhaben finanzieren können
ohne die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
überlasten denn es ist ja der alte
preisfahrt auf den sich unser Land
vormals schon hat einstellen können ich
glaube ein ausgewogenes gutes Paket das
unser Land
voranbringt schönen
Dank
ja das war die Pressekonferenz von
Bundeskanzler Scholz Vizekanzler habbeck
und Finanzminister Lindner zur Einigung
im Haushaltsstreit wir sehen es Fragen
an die Journalistinnen und Journalisten
waren nicht zugelassen aber wir wollen
jetzt noch mal ganz in Ruhe aufdröseln
und besprechen was der denn gerade
gesagt wurde wir erinnern uns vor fast
vier Wochen hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht eine Umwidmung
von Krediten in Höhe von 60 Milliarden
Euro im Bundeshaushalt
2021 für null und nichtig erklärt und
das bedeutete eben dass ich jetzt alle
noch mal neu zusammensetzen mussten und
eben einen neuen Haushalt im einen neuen
Haushalt beschließen und sich darauf
einigen mussten wir wollen darüber
sprechen mit Professor Marcel Fratscher
vom Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung und wir sprechen
jetzt aber erstmal mit unserer ZDF
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Britta buchol
in Berlin guten Tag hallo hallo Britta
Britta wir haben eben drei sehr müde
aussehende und offensichtlich auch etwas
erschöpfte Männer gesehen die uns gesagt
haben dass im Prinzip die Regierung an
ihren Zielen festhält aber das Galles
alles mit weniger Geld was waren jetzt
für dich die wesentlichen Punkte na das
interessanteste oder spannendste ist ja
erstm dass die Schuldenbremse bleibt
also dass die Notlage für die Ukraine
nicht erklärt wird weil das war ja der
Hauptstreitpunkt n muss man gleich dazu
sagen zunächst nicht erklärt wird weil
der Bundeskanzler hat sich das ja
eigentlich so ein bisschen offen
gehalten ob das innerhalb des nächsten
Jahres noch passieren könnte und äh ja
der Hintergrund ist sicher sicherlich
dass die FDP das ja nicht wollte die
sagt mit dem Geld was man habe müsse man
auch auskommen und es müsste jetzt nicht
von vorne rein gleich wieder eine
Notlage erklärt werden da wurd sich aber
so ein kleines Hintertürchen seitens des
Bundeskanzlers auf offen gehalten aber
das war sicher erstmal das
Überraschendste dass dieser Weg eben
nicht gegangen wird sondern dass geguckt
wird wo bekommen wir Geld her und da
wurden ja eben viele Wege genannt wo man
so ein bisschen das Gefühl hat von jedem
einen bisschen jeder muss ein bisschen
was geben aber im Grunde der große ja
der große Wurf oder dieser große Moment
wo man sagt die oder die müssen jetzt
abgeben der war jetzt nicht dabei was
ich ganz interessant finde sind wirklich
die sogenannten klimaschädlichen
Subventionen wo sie ran wollen also das
ist einmal der agrariesel das gibt's ja
schon seit 1967 und zwar kriegen
praktisch Bauern und alle die im
forstwirtschaftlichen Bereich sind den
Diesel subventioniert und ähm ja im
Grunde so eine Steuererleichterung und
die soll dann nun in ich weiß nicht ob
sie komplett wegfallen soll das glaube
ich eher nicht sondern sie soll weniger
bezuschusst werden ähnliches Modell ist
beim Kerosin woh geplant also bisher
Flugzeuge die in Deutschland tanken
kriegen da auch eine Steuervergünstigung
die auch entweder komplett wegfallen
soll oder zum Teil wegfallen soll
jedenfalls auf nationaler Ebene denn das
Problem ist natürlich die Flieger tanken
dann eben woanders wo es billiger ist
ist ein bisschen logisch aber eben da
will man ran der Finanzminister hat das
ja gerade genannt dass man eben Dinge
die alt sind also alte Subventionen
sozusagen weg haben will und dafür will
man eben neue Möglichkeiten schaffen was
würdest du sagen welche Partei hat sich
da jetzt in diesen Gesprächen
durchsetzen können tja das ist äh noch
schwer einzuschätzen da müssen wir
wahrscheinlich die Details noch mal
angucken für die FDP für die Liberalen
ist es natürlich schon mal aus ihrer
Sicht ein großer Erfolg das ist keine
Steuererhöhung geben wird denn das haben
sie ja immer ausgeschlossen und das war
ja im Grunde auch schon als sie in die
Ampel eingetreten sind ihr großes
Versprechen keine Steuererhöhung mit uns
und der zweite Punkt der Liberalen war
ja immer die Schuldenbremse einhalten
auch das haben sie jetzt mutmaßlich für
2024 geschafft jedenfalls erstmal ich
möchte das immer so ein bisschen
einschränken weil eben auch der
Bundeskanzler die Hintertür aufgehalten
hat aber gleichzeitig werd es jetzt
Subventionen auf klimaschädliche ähm ähm
also klimaschädliche Subventionen werden
halt anders jetzt besteuert und das ist
sicher nicht im Sinne der Liberalen und
das ist sicher etwas was aus dem habbeck
Ministerium stärker hervorgebracht WD
dass man da halt stärker rangeht und das
dritte ist das auch beim
sozialstattkürzungen stattfinden sollen
das hatte jetzt Scholz selber gar nicht
genannt aber Lindner hat das genannt 1,5
Milliarden will man dort einsammeln also
von daher haben alle glaube ich in irg
in irgendeiner Form Federn lassen müssen
in welchem Verhältnis da steht das
müssen wir glaube ich erst oder können
wir erst bewerten wenn wir es uns im
Detail genau ansehen können mm aber
trotzdem geht's schon so eine Richtung
kannst du in ungefähr jetzt einschätzen
nachdem was gesagt wurde auf welen
Kosten dieser Haushalt gehen wird
ähm ich glaube das ist wirklich noch ein
bisschen zu früh weil es im Grunde der
KTF der Klima und transformationsfond da
sind ja 60 Milliarden drin die jetzt
irgendwie anders wieder eingesammelt
werden müssen wo es auch nicht um 2024
nur sondern das in verschiedene Jahre
eingeteilt ist und wo dieses Geld jetzt
am Ende herkommt das haben sie jetzt
Detail noch nicht genannt das haben alle
nur so ein bisschen angedeutet Herr
habbeck hat das z.B auch genannt man
müsste dann neu priorisieren und so
weiter das ist noch nicht ganz klar auf
dem ersten Blick würde ich sagen die
Liberalen haben sich insofern
durchgesetzt dass ihre zwei
hopforderungen jetzt erstmal halten
können und das ist für sie der große
Schritt gewesen aber ob sie sich
insgesamt durchsetzen können da wäre ich
jetzt noch vor vorsichtig also ich würde
da im Moment noch niemanden zum Gewinner
oder Verlierer erklären wollen intern
war ja wirklich von einem Nervenkrieg
die Rede gewesen ähm kann man das sagen
war das tatsächlich jetzt so eine
Zerreißprobe für die Bundesregierung auf
alle Fälle das kann man definitiv so
sagen heute haben sie ja wohl bis kurz
nach 5 Uhr noch zusammengesessen Herr
habbeck hat dann morgens getwittert wir
sind durch und das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dass das ja wirklich vor vier
Wochen kam das Urteil das war ein
Schockmoment für die Ampel denn man hat
sich vieles vorstellen könen aber nicht
dass es so dick g kommt man hat sich
schon vorstellen können dass man
irgendwie Veränderungen vornehmen muss
und umschichten kann aber dass der der
KTF betroffen ist der WSV betroffen ist
im Grunde der ganze bundesushalt 24 noch
mal angeguckt werden muss das war
sicherlich niemanden klar in der Form
und da hat auch das Finanzministerium so
ein bisschen verschlafen und jetzt war
das in den letzten Wochen ja immer
wieder so dass wir dachten okay heute
kommt die Entscheidung und sie kam dann
wieder nicht also die Verhandlungen
waren ganz offensichtlich sehr schwierig
noch dazu kam dass beim SPD Parteitag
letzte Woche noch mal mehr Druck
aufgebaut wurde der Bundeskanzler Scholz
wollte unbedingt eine schnelle
Verhandlungsrunde und gleichzeitig hat
er ganz klar gemacht im Bereich sozialen
soll nicht so viel abgebaut werden da
kam ja auch von der FDP wiederum
Forderung beim Bürgergeld noch mal
stärker ranzugehen das kommt wohl nicht
in dem Maße also von daher der
Nervenkrieg war da und man kann sagen
die sind wahrscheinlich alle Beteiligten
jetzt froh dass man wenigstens soweit
jetzt gekommen ist lass uns noch mal
kurz auf dieses Stichwort ukrainehilfen
eingehen da hieß es dann da war die Rede
von einem Überschreitens beseschluss der
dann da möglicherweise kommen kann
vielleicht kannst Du noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen worauf hat man sich da
geeinigt na die ukrainehilfe soll in dem
Sinne wie sie beschlossen wurde erstmal
kommen und das
das ist natürlich ein gute Nachricht für
die Ukraine das ist klar dass man da
nicht rangeht und wie man das jetzt
schafft ohne die Notlage zu erklären das
tja das li eigentlich noch so ein
bisschen im Dunkeln das müssen wir uns
Detail dann genau angucken die
ukrainehilfe ist ja ein großer Batzen
mit mehreren Milliarden Euro und ja also
da sie soll jedenfalls aus dem jetzt so
eingeplanten Haushalt finanziert werden
so viel kann man sagen und ein ander
Punkt ist dass ja auch die größte
Oppositionspartei im Bundestag die CDU
mächtig Druck gemacht hat in wieefern
würdest du sagen ist diese Lösung im
Haushaltsstreit siehst du da auch
Zugeständnisse an die CDU auf alle Fälle
das muss man auf alle so Fälle so sagen
weil die Frage ob man jetzt erneut eine
Notlage erklärt auch für die Ukraine
hing ja immer damit zusammen dass
möglicherweise diese Notlage dann auch
vom Bundesverfassungsgericht keinen
Bestand hätte das war ja immer der große
Punkt um den es da ging und ähm da hat
haben die Liberalen immer sehr gewarnt
dass sie das sehen dass das halt wieder
ein keinbestand hätte dann hätten wir an
dem Punkt möglicherweise gestanden an
dem wir jetzt auch stehen das haben auch
mehrere Juristen so gesehen und dadurch
dass die Union immer wieder gesagt hat
sie würden im gegebenenfalls klagen
wollen also den Klageweg gehen ähm stand
natürlich die Ampel massiv unter Druck
und das hat natürlich auch dafür zuu
geführt dass sie diesen Weg am Ende
vielleicht nicht gegangen sind oder man
möchte dazu sagen noch nicht gegangen
sind weil noch mal in so einer Situation
zu sein wie jetzt das wollte natürlich
wahrscheinlich niemand gleichzeitig muss
man sagen die SPD hat auch wieder Druck
gemacht da wollten es ja viele da haben
viele es nicht gesehen dass man den Weg
eben nicht gehen kann dass man die
Milliarden eben nicht durch eine erneute
Notlage beschaffen könnte und auch die
Grünen haben gesagt diesen Weg können
wir gehen da gab es unterschiedliche
Sichtweisen und gleichzeitig hat die
treibt die Union kann man fast schon
sagen da die Ampel so ein bisschen vor
sich her weil sie natürlich sagt wenn es
nicht verfassungskonform ist dann darf
die Ampel auch nicht so handeln das ist
ja auch legitim das so zu sehen aber das
hat natürlich sehr viel Druck aufgebaut
und hat auch dafür gesorgt dass nun
wahrscheinlich die Ampel den Weg so geht
wie sie eben uns vorgetragen haben mm
jetzt hat sich ja die Regierung geeinigt
wie geht's jetzt weiter ja das ist eine
gute Frage also der nächste Schritt ist
ja dass die Haushälter sich
zusammensetzen und da im Grunde
ja sich sich die Kop Köpfe zermatern was
das alles im Detail für 2024 bedeutet
dann kommt so eine sogenannte
Bereinigungssitzung das ist der Moment
wo die Haushälter meistens ist das eine
Nachtsitzung bis tief in die Nacht
zusammensitzen und den kompletten
Haushaltsentwurf auf stellen diese
Bereinigungssitzung könnte jetzt dieses
Jahr noch passieren das haben habe ich
eben auch schon gelesen das wurde aus
der SPD schon vorgeschlagen oder halt
Anfang Januar und dann beginnt in jedem
Fall erst im Januar das ganze
parlamentarische Verfahren das heißt
erste Lesung im Bundestag zweite Lesung
im Bundestag dritte Lesung und dann wird
möglicherweise natürlich der Entwurf
entsprechend auch noch mal angepasst bis
er dann verabschiedet wird und nach
stand jetzt wäre das so Ende Januar und
dann muss noch der Bundesrat dem ganzen
zustimmen die die nächste Sitzung des
Bundesrates wäre dann im in der 1
Februar Woche ja und dann wäre der
Bundeshaushalt 2024 wirklich
verabschiedet und so ist im Moment wohl
der Plan dass es halt so laufen wird
okay also das bedeutet es wird noch ein
paar Wochen dauern am Britta noch ganz
kurz eine Frage zu einem ganz anderen
Thema da bnt sich aber offensichtlich
auch wieder was an es heißt heute
Vormittag der asylpakt sei geplatzt was
hörst du da kocht da jetzt wieder neuer
Krach in der Koalition hoch ja man kann
sagen die eine Kuh ist vom Eis und die
nächste wird draaufgeschoben also das
ist
ja das ist schon so ein bisschen irre
aber das geht da um das sogenannte
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz also man
spricht auch manchmal so
umgangssprachlich von turboabschiebung
das hat die Ampel ja lange diskutiert
und äh und in in vielen Sitzungen und
Nachtsitzungen und so weiter einen
Kompromiss gefunden und dieser ganze
Kompromiss wurde dann am 28 Oktober
verabschiedet vom Kabinett und dann
geht's Hal halt auch ins
parlamentarische Verfahren und das
sollte in diesem Jahr noch passieren da
hat man sich geeinigt das Ganze vor
Weihnachten
ja durchzubekommen weil man ja auch sagt
diese turboabschiebung sollen dann auch
möglich sein und deshalb müsse es
möglichst schnell gehen und nun war
gestern schon klar ja es wird
wahrscheinlich dies Jahr nicht mehr
verabschiedet das liegt vor allen Dingen
am Widerstand wohl der Grünen die da
viele Themen wohl noch mal aufmachen
wollen
ja und ob das ganze jetzt geplatzt ist
oder E nur erst im Januar oder Februar
kommt das ist im Grunde die große Frage
die hier im Moment im Raum steht
das hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab ob
die Forderungen die dann nun seitens der
Grünen kommen ich nenne es mal
umgangssprach realistisch sind oder eben
nicht sie haben da wohl die Idee dass
ein Anwalt das ganze Verfahren noch
überprüfen soll und demjenigen der
abgeschoben werden muss zur Seite stehen
so habe ich das gerade gelesen das würde
natürlich
wahrscheinlich in der Praxis dann das
zeitlich so verzögern dass es dann eben
doch keine Turbo Abschiebung sein könnte
aber das ja das werden wir jetzt sehen
in wie weit sie sich da wieder
zusammenraufen und in wie fern sie das
Gesetz jetzt wirklich in den Bundestag
bekommen oder ob es dann wirklich ganz
auf Eis gelegt wird okay dann warten wir
mal ab wie sich das weiterentwickelt
vielen Dank Britta Bucholz im ZDF
Hauptstadtstudio Berlin mach's gut
tschüss tschüss
danke und wir wollen noch mal jetzt
weiter reden über die Einigung im
Haushaltsstreit und das tun wir jetzt
mit Professor Marcel frat vom Deutschen
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung hallo
Herr Fratscher hallo guten Tag schön
dass sie so spontan Zeit für uns hatten
war ja auch nicht erwartbar dass es
jetzt heute Mittag um 12 Uhr gleich eine
Pressekonferenz gibt was würden Sie
sagen sie haben das ja auch verfolgt
welches Signal sendet diese Einigung
jetzt an die
Wirtschaft die Einigung sendet kein
gutes Signal an die Wirtschaft ähm auf
der einen Seite wird versprochen
die meisten zusagen werden eingehalten
also
die 15 Milliarden Euro für Intel in
Magdeburg und für TSMC in in Dresden
werden eingehalten viele andere der
Hilfen auch der geringeren Stromsteuer
das wird erfüllt aber das klare Signal
dieser Einigung ist ähm keine weiteren
Schulden keine Steuererhöhung das sind
die roten Linien äh Investitionen und
andere Ausgaben müssen gekürzt werden
das ist das klare Bild das hat auch der
Bundeskanzler gesagt wir müssen mit
weniger Geld auskommen so hat er das
mehr oder weniger wortwörtlich gesagt
ähm wenn man sich ehrlich macht die 60
Milliarden Euro die äh durch das ja die
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgericht zurückgenommen
wurden die werden jetzt fehlen nicht nur
im Jahr 2024 sondern auch in den
Folgejahren und dafür hat man keine
Lösung gefunden außer dass man an
einigen Ecken und Enden kürzen will
sicherlich bei manchen Subventionen ist
es sinnvoll aber ähm letztlich ist es
eine Mogelpackung es ist man hat das
Problem in die Zukunft verschoben äh man
hat hier keine dauerhafte Lösung für die
fehlenden 60 Milliarden Euro gefunden
und m auch keine Antwort darauf was man
wirklich tut um zukünftig mehr
Investition tätigen zu können wenn ich
mal in den Chat schaue da schreibt tub
machine schafft doch die Schuldenbremse
ab im internationalen
investitionswettkampf wird Deutschland
bald
abgehängt na ja die
Schuldenbremse gibt ja durchaus auch die
Möglichkeit ähm Ausnahmen Notsituation
zu erklären
kurzfristig wird eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse das Problem für 2024 und
2025 nicht lösen da muss man sich
ehrlich machen die Reform der
Schuldenbremse ist notwendig die wird
aber jetzt in dieser Situation nicht
helfen sondern jetzt wäre es dringend
gewesen klares Signal zu setzen wo will
man Prioritäten setzen und das hat die
Bundesregierung mit dieser Entscheidung
getan nämlich
es gibt keine weiteren Ausnahmen man ja
man lässt sich so ein bisschen die
Hintertür durch den Ukraine Krieg offen
das hat der Bundes Kanzler angedeutet
aber letztlich ist die Botschaft es
werden Ausgaben gekürzt und man versucht
auch niemanden wirklich weh zu tun also
so die großen Subventionen äh wie beim
dieselprivileg beispielsweise für
autofahreren Autofahrer das hat man
nicht angetastet das werden fast 8
Milliarden Euro gewesen der
Bundesfinanzminister hat es ganz stolz
erklärt und hat gesagt die
Einkommensteuer
Entlastung für vor allem für die
Spitzenverdiener von 15 Milliarden Euro
pro Jahr die bleiben weiterhin bestehen
auch das wir chaft
stabilisierungsgesetz von knapp 7
Milliarden Euro auch das wird weiter
bestehen bleiben
also ich sehe das sehr kritisch es ist
letztlich eine Mogelpackung es löst
keines der Probleme und es bedeutet und
das ist eben auch die wichtige
Perspektive für die Wirtschaft auf auf
Absicht auf absehbare Zeit wird es
erstmal nicht mehr öffentliche
Investition geben mal ganz konkret die
Frage was bedeutet diese Einigung für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
na ja für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
bedeutet sie äh beispielsweise soll ja
der CO2 Preis jetzt wieder Steller
schneller und stärker steigen ähm heißt
es manche Dinge werden teurer werden ähm
und ähm das ist ja per se nicht schlech
der CO2 Preis muss steigen aber die
Koalition bleibt eben das klimageld
schuldig die Idee war ja dass
co2einnahmen zumindest ein erheblicher
Teil von den CO2 Einnahmen in der Form
eines eines klimagelds an die
BürgerInnen Bürger zurückgeht da hat die
Bundesregierung jetzt gar nichts gesagt
sie hat gesagt ja mehr Einnahmen durch
schnellere Erhöhung des CO2 Preises aber
das Geld geben wir nicht zurück beim
Bürgergeld soweit wir wissen 1,5
Milliarden Euro an Einsparung
ähm ja das da werden einige weniger
haben das muss man auch in aller
Ehrlichkeit sagen ähm also für die
meisten BürgerInnen Bürger bedeutet dies
kurzfristig eher eine stärkere Belastung
keine Entlastung und perspektivisch auf
die nächsten Jahre eben auch nicht
unbedingt mehr Geld was was fließen wird
es ist öfter in der Pressekonferenz die
Rede gewesen von den klimaschädlichen
Subventionen was ist da konkret gemeint
vielleicht müssen wir das auch noch mal
genauer erklären
ähm klimaschädliche Subventionen
bedeuten dass vor allem fossile
Energieträger nicht zum der Art und
Weise steuerlich belastet werden äh wie
sie es sein sollten um die wirklichen
Kosten äh des CO2 Ausstoßes durch diese
fossile Energieträger abzudecken das
gilt beispielsweise äh für die
Besserstellung äh bei dieselbenzin
gegenüber Normalbenzin
ähm agrarbenzi Agrardiesel also nur für
die Bauer bäerinen bäuern da wird es
gekürzt aber nicht für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger ähm fossile Subventionen ähm
ja das das ist jetzt ein konkretes
Beispiel aber auch in vielen anderen
Bereichen bei vielen anderen Produkten
z.B bei landwirtschaftlichen Produkten m
sind müssten die Preise eigentlich höher
sein um die wirklichen Kosten
wiederzuspiegeln und diese Subventionen
belaufen sich jedes Jahr knapp auf 60
bis 65 Milliarden Euro die
klimaschädliche Emissionen
subventioniert werden vor allem bei
fossilen Energieträgern das ist die
größten Ordnung über die wir sprechen
das heißt sprechen wir noch einmal
kurz über die Wirtschaft
welche Entwicklungen sehen Sie für die
Unternehmen in Deutschland
für die Unternehmen in Deutschland
bedeutet diese Entscheidung erst einmal
ein bisschen mehr Klarheit zumindest für
das nächste Jahr das ist gut ein Teil
der Unsicherheit wurde damit reduziert
ähm aber langfristig bleiben natürlich
sehr viele offene Fragen Unternehmen
brauchen bessere Rahmenbedingung sie
brauchen eine bessere Infrastruktur äh
nicht nur bei Verkehr bei der Deutschen
Bahn auch bessere digitale Infrastruktur
bessere Energieinfrastruktur
beispielsweise wurde bei sal Solar
gekürzt ähm und wie das finanziert
werden soll wie das jetzt auf die
Schiene gesetzt würden werden soll das
bleibt letztlich mit dieser Entscheidung
offen also wie ich sagte man hat jetzt
für
2024 eine Einigung ausgehandelt aber das
heißt dass eigentlich weniger Geld 2025
und danach auch zur Verfügung stehen
wird und wie diese notwendigen
Rahmenbedingungen für die Unternehmen
geschaffen werden sollen das bleibt
offen und deshalb ist es kurzfristig
sicherlich erstmal ein Aufatmen für die
Unternehmen aber langfristig löst es die
groß Probleme wie kann die Infrastruktur
verbessert werden wie kann das
Bildungssystem verbessert werden und
damit Fachkräfte zu einem größeren Maße
da sind diese großen Herausforderungen
langfristig bleiben hiermit ungelöst
jetzt gab es ja immer Warnungen vor
allem von Sozialverbänden dass die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse eben auf
Kosten der Sozialleistungen geht jetzt
hat Finanzminister Lindner ja auf der
einen Seite von Einsparung von 1,5
Milliarden gesprochen auf der anderen
Seite sagt er das wird aber nicht
schlimm weil er von mehr
Treffsicherheit spricht ist das denn
realistisch man kann überall auch in den
Sozialsystem sicherlich zielgenauer
werden so gesehen das Ziel dass die
Menschen die Leistung bekommen die sie
wirklich benötigen und die Menschen
dieses nicht benötigen es nicht bekommen
ist ja ist ja klar das da kann ja keiner
was gegen sagen nur wie das wirklich in
der Realität umsetzen will bin ich sehr
gespannt
letztlich befürchte ich wird es bedeuten
dass doch eine ganze Reihe von Menschen
die bedürftig sind und wenig haben hier
weniger Leistung bekommen werden und
das ist letztlich auch das perfide
dieser Botschaft es wird bei Menschen
mit sehr wenig Einkommen gekürzt aber
beispielsweise bei den hochvermögenden
bei denen die wirklich wenig Steuern
zahlen zum Teil mit ihren Vermögen
komplett an der Steuer vorbei
kommen
wird eben wenn solche Ausnahmen nicht
abgeschafft also Zielgenauigkeit scheint
für den Bundesfinanzminister und auch
für die ampelregierung wenn man sich
jetzt diese Pressekonferenz anhört vor
allem für die Menschen mit wenig
Einkommen zu gelten für die Menschen die
sehr viel haben anscheinend nicht ich
habe die Frage eben der Korrespondentin
Britta Buchholz gestellt ich würde sie
Ihnen aber gerne trotzdem auch noch mal
stellen weil mich ihre Einschätzung
interessieren würde haben sie in dieser
haushaltseinigung sehen sie da am ersten
die Handschrift der FDP gefühlt hatte
Finanzminister Lindner ja eben in der
Pressekonferenz den größten
Redeanteil für mich ist die FDP der
klare Gewinner dieser Einigung die FDP
hat es geschafft ihre beiden roten
Linien durchzusetzen keine zusätzlichen
Schulden Schuldenbremse einhalten und
zweitens keine Steuererhöhungen
also eher Steuerentlastungen für die
Spitzenverdiener das hat die FDP
durchsetzen können SPD und Grüne müssen
einschneiden also Beschneidungen oder
weniger Gelder für Klimaschutz für
Investition und auch für Soziales
auskommen also für mich ist klar die FDP
der große Gewinner dieser Einigung ich
würde gerne noch mal ein paar Fragen aus
dem Chat stellen da fragt Max Mustermann
Herr Fratscher denken sie dass die
Schuldenbremse sinnvoll ist ist es nicht
so dass jede Firma investieren muss und
wir sollten auch in die Zukunft
investieren ich halte die Schuldenbremse
so wie sie ausgestaltet ist für falsch
und für konterproduktiv weil sie blind
dafür ist wofür der Staat Geld ausgibt
ob das jetzt der öffentliche Konsum ist
oder öffentliche Investitionen und
gerade in diesen schwierigen Zeiten ich
will nicht sagen Krisenzeiten aber
schwierigen Zeiten für Deutschland in
dem wirklich massiv zusätzliche
öffentliche Investitionen notwendig sind
bei Klimaschutz bei einer guten
Infrastruktur digitale Infrastruktur
Verkehrsinfrastruktur im
Bildungsbereich bei Innovation und
jungen Unternehmen zu helfen ähm das B
da bedeutet diese Schuldenbremse so wie
sie ausgestaltet ist letztlich weniger
öffentliche Investition das wird die
Leistungsfähigkeit der Wirtschaft eher
Schwächen wenn man jetzt über eine
Schuldenbremse nachdenkt es ist ja
spricht ja nichts dagegen dass der Staat
sich kluge Regeln gibt die dazu führen
dass der Staat sich nicht unendlich
Verschulden kann ähm deshalb ist es klug
darüber nachzudenken wie man die
Schuldenbremse reformieren kann ich
finde das sollte man dringend tun nur
mein Punkt ist das wird jetzt für 2024
2025 eine solche Reform nicht helfen
denn diese Reform erfordert eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit im Bundestag das muss
vorbereitet werden das wird also jetzt
in dieser akuten Situation nicht helfen
aber langfristig denke ich ist es
dringend äh notwendig dass diese
Schuldenbremse so reformiert wird dass
sie nicht zu einer Bremse für
Investitionen wird die die die
Leistungsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft sondern dass sie wirklich
klug ähm die Schulden auf der
konsumseite begrenzt aber nicht die
Investition bremst mm es gibt noch eine
Frage von Markus hermsberger wie gedenkt
die Regierung auf die Inflation zu
reagieren im neuen
Haushalt ja auf die Inflation reagiert
die Bundesregierung
eigentlich kaum
ähm man geht davon aus dass 2024 die
Inflation wieder im Normalmaß liegen
wird bei 2inhal 3% also nicht mehr die
8% vom letzten Jahr oder 5 Hal 6% in
diesem Jahr da wo die Bundesregierung
reagiert hat ist mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetetzt das ist
was der Finanzminister eben in der
Pressekonferenz
mit der Entlastung bei den
Spitzenverdienern erwähnt hat hier gehen
15 16 Milliarden Euro
über das inflationsausgleichsgesetz an
Entlastung bei der
Einkommensteuer wird geleistet und das
kommt eben vor allem den
Spitzenverdienern zugute
deshalb ist dieses Paket was jetzt die
Bundesregierung beschlossen hat na ja
nicht unbedingt Umverteilung von oben
nach unten sondern wahrscheinlich eher
von unten nach oben mm und noch eine
letzte Frage von Cedric auf Youtube wie
kann man es rechtfertigen jetzt am KTF
also am Klima und
transformationssfond zu kürzen er
schreibt er findet es
unverantwortbar ja die Kürzung beim
Klima und transformationsf ist ja nicht
eine Entscheidung der Bundesregierung
sondern des Bundesverfassungsgericht die
gesagt haben so wie das aufgesetzt ist
geht es nicht die 60 Milliarden können
so nicht genutzt werden und die
Bundesregierung hat sich jetzt letzlich
entschieden zu sagen okay dann haben wir
die Gelder halt nicht dann müssen wir
irgendwo anders einsparen und wir
brauchen ein bisschen Trickserei ähm um
letztlich ähm ja die Gelder so zu kürzen
dass es mit der Schuldenbremse vereinbar
ist
ähm ich bin enttäuscht dass die
Bundesregierung nicht den Mut hatte zu
sagen wir brauchen aber diese 60
Milliarden Euro die sind dringend not
not wendig und dann finden wir eben
einen anderen Weg um diese 60 Milliarden
Euro äh zu haben das ist möglich das
zeigt das Sondervermögen Bundeswehr was
im letzten Jahr 2022 beschlossen wurde
wo es dann eine wo es letztlich einen
Verfassungsrang bekommen hat also wo
letztlich der gesamte Bundestag
zugestimmt hat ja das hat eine so große
Bedeutung diese 100 Milliarden Euro für
Verteidigung für die Bundeswehr dass wir
es in die ins Grundgesetz in die
Verfassung schreiben und damit rechtens
machen das hätte man jetzt auch äh mit
mit Geldern für Klimaschutz für
Transformation machen können und
eigentlich meiner Ansicht nach müssen
damit hätte man das Problem nicht nur
für nächstes Jahr sondern auch für die
kommenden Jahre gelöst aber diesen
großen Wurf sich ehrlich zu machen was
braucht der Staat an Geld das hat die
Bundesregierung jetzt in diesem Paket
nicht geleistet deshalb ist es für mich
kein großes Paket so wie der Vizekanzler
das genannt hat sondern eher eine
Mogelpackung ein Weg dran vorbei das
Problem eher in die Zukunft zu schieben
und so gesehen ja löst dieses Paket
jetzt wirklich die langfristigen
Herausforderung eher nicht Herr
Fratscher ich danke Ihnen sehr für ihre
Erklärungen ihre Einschätzungen und ihre
klaren Worte danke schön machen sie es
gut tschüss sehr gerne ja das war ZDF
heute live zur Lösung zur Einigung im
Haushaltsstreit ich danke euch für eure
Fragen und eure Kommentare und wünsche
euch noch einen schönen Tag bis bald
tschüss
ه